well these days you hear plenty of
stories about the labor shortage
businesses just can't find enough bodies
to fill jobs but at one local business
there are plenty to go around john
langler explains
ever driven along d.i and wondered
what's in this place i mean sure there's
a sign and it seems obvious and there's
things that look like people on the
outside but what's really in there
mannequins
mannequins
mannequins
you get the point then we get to our
area where we have torsos this is alison
wainwright ceo and founder of las vegas
mannequins you mean i know about your
problem mannequins what problem exactly
it's a lot of hard work dealing with
body parts wainwright started las vegas
mannequins in 2004 in her garage it was
a side hustle while working at local
conventions she saw a business
everyone always walks in here they're
like wow oh my goodness now she's in
this enormous warehouse on desert inn
it's full of fake people
i think they're cool to have around your
house you'd be surprised the amount of
people that come in just because they
want a mannequin business is good art
galleries to conventions
retail stores even during the pandemic
as the world fell all around us we also
had random requests people who were at
home and you know might have purchased
guns and they were looking for things
for
shooting targets sounds reassuring i
mean we have kind of a niche product
they're in stores and studios malls and
conventions artistic homes and unusual
poses there's different mannequin trends
that happen every year it's a lot more
technical than you'd think there's a
pretty high demand just given the
variety of businesses and customers that
we work with oh you can put your card in
there now wainwright is like everyone
else struggling to find workers
if only she could bring her product to
life no i have not been caught talking
to mannequins yet and luckily they have
not spoken to me let them say they're
crazy
i really believe that everybody needs a
mannequin john langler live local now